edward cabrera heads out there cameras
following every step of his way from the
dugout all the way out to the mound his
major league debut very exciting time
for him and for the marlins and that is
chopped to third anderson from foul
territory throws across his body and
it's picked by aguilar that's some big
league defense
a big time play from b.a goes to the
backhand just in front of the third base
bag throws on the run
right on the mark nice job by aguilar at
first and he goes to work
and here's the ball grounded to the
right side up with it isan diaz throws
to first and a one two three first
inning in his big league debut for
edward cabrera retiring thomas escobar
and soto this is his fifth start with
washington sixth of his career but the
dodgers 2019 minor league player of the
year last time there was a full minor
league season traded over from la to dc
did he go he moved his hands
and confirmed by ron culpa the third
base umpire for the first down all right
17 strikeouts this year for josiah gray
on the curve ball graze into the line
look like they're going up with a
fastball here it comes swinging a ground
ball left side escomar to his left has
it his throw across to josh bell in time
for the hour edward cabrera goes to work
his second major league inning he faces
josh bell to start things off line drive
right at the left fielder and over a
couple of steps to his right hour left
lewis princeton is there and bell is out
on a liner and four up four down for
edward cabrera two down nobody on no
score second inning and first ball
hitting this ball is put in play out
into right center and it's caught there
by jesus sanchez so kibum lines out
to sanchez and a quick one two three
inning two down no score anderson at
second base an opportunity for alfaro to
drive in a run anderson leading away at
second base here's the pitch and here's
a hard ground ball past the third
baseman t boom that's going to get brian
anderson home one to nothing marlins on
alfaro's strong single through the left
side here's the pitch
and here's a ball hit out into left
center and that is going to get down and
making a turn at second is el faro but
he'll hold up right there de la cruz
dunks a single out into left center
marlins are at first and second for the
pitcher wouldn't you know
here's the pitch swung on jammed him on
a fastball popped up and the right
fielder comes on juan soto will make the
catch cabrera
is out first ball hitting popped it up
to soto the marlins get a run
on a walk and two hits in the inning
first pitch to garcia and garcia hits a
line drive to right for the base hit
so on the first pitch in the third
inning the nationals have their first
hit and base runner garcia who is
hitting 208 here comes the o2 and that
strike three call there's the first big
league strikeout for edward cabrera
here's the next pitch to gray and it's
bunted fowl and there's another
strikeout
for edward cabrera gray could not get
the sacrifice bunt down here's the 3-1
pitch and thomas swings and hits a high
fly ball left center going back the
center fielder right up against the
signage out there de la cruz makes the
catch terrific play
by brian de la cruz tracking that ball
and believe me when you get that close
to that wall those lights are bright
they're hot and he went right up against
the fence that protects
the glass
jazz is the only defender on the left
side diaz anderson and
aguilar on the right side anderson has
it down a second one they'll throw the
first two they get the double play and
that goes five six three and bats for
the second time here and he flies out
again to left field first ball hitting
louis sprinton puts that away and that's
it
for the nationals no runs one hit nobody
left on base
and josiah gray equal opportunity on the
outs three walks one intentional and
only three singles given up himself
swinging a miss down
goes chisholm for strike three fifth
strike out of the game for josiah gray
one away in the bottom of the fifth
inning
here's a ball blasted into the air to
left center hernandez back at the wall
leaping can't get it the ball is off his
glove and off the wall
and making a turn at second is jesus
sanchez but he'll return to the bag and
hold up right there with a long double
to the humana sign kicking the pinch
swinging a ground ball right side slowly
and bell has it he'll race the bag
himself
for the out the marlins had one shot to
get sanchez in and brinson grounded out
softly the other way to first base the
year for edward cabrera and dave he has
been phenomenal through the first five
fun to watch
here's a ground ball to third down at
second one over the first two
another double play the third turn by
the marlins five
four
three so here's the guy who's walked
twice brian anderson here's the 0-1
pitch brian anderson sends the ball to
iron deep out toward left center field
this is
for a home run
ryan anderson with a lead-off home run
in the bottom of the six then the
marlins double their lead
and that is in there over the inside
corner with a fastball strike three
called so gray comes back to get
strikeout number six
after being behind in the count three
and one here's the pitch
swing and miss struck him out with a
curve so gray comes back after giving up
the home run to retire the next three
including a pair of strikeouts and
edward cabrera in
pretty much total control through six
here's josh bell over two two line outs
to left here it comes swinging a drive
straight away center field and deep
dealer crews racing back it's over his
head and it is gone it just clears and
josh bell has tied the game with one big
swing on an o2 pitch home run number 21
for bell
breaks up the shutout bit of the rookie
cabrera and all of a sudden in the blink
of an eye this game is tied the
nationals two and the marlins two so
we're gonna drive to left field deep
back on this one is brinson to the
warning track to the wall and it's gone
and the nationals go back to back and
the nationals have their first lead of
the night three to two home run number
seven for yadiel
here comes donnie that's gonna be it for
edward cabrera in his major league debut
six brilliant innings from him tonight
so jesus aguilar will be the batter
magnuris the runner at third base
that is toward right center field and
that is gonna get down it'll tie the
game on another big hit by jesus aguilar
marlon's a chance to walk things off
tied at three de la cruz is at third
with two outs here's the pitch fastball
is popped up
shallow left
in comes yadiel hernandez under it and
he makes the catch
to retire the side what a job by austin
bowles dylan floro is on the pitch for
the marlins their fifth pitcher tonight
is a ground ball base in through the
right side
sanchez is up with it here comes kibum
fro gets all the way about
and they got him
what a throw from sanchez in right field
to cut down what would have been the
go-ahead run intentionally load the
bases now and jorge alfaro will get the
first shot and here's the pitch and
there's a base hit out into left center
and this game is over
home to score
is jesus sanchez and the marlins have
won in 10 innings and snapped an eight
game losing streak
you